we have breaking news this morning a new
coronavirus vaccine is getting high
marks in clinical trials
novovac says its two-dose vaccine is
about 90 percent effective
and is safe after being tested in nearly
30 000 trial participants
the company plans to ask for government
permission to distribute the vaccine by
the end of september
it's intended to target by the virus in
low and middle
income countries over the weekend
leaders from the world's seven
wealthiest democracies committed to
donate more than 1 billion vaccine doses
to poorer countries over the next year
the u.s
is contributing about half of those
doses through a partnership with
pfizer jan crawford spoke with pfizer's
ceo and chairman albert vorla
about this historic vaccine pledge and
the challenges ahead
dr fauci has kind of sounded alarm about
this delta variant how confident are you
that our current vaccine that your
current vaccine is going to protect
against that i feel quite comfortable to
cover it
we will not need a special vaccine for
it the car and vaccine
should cover it with growing concern
over the delta variant across the world
pfizer ceo albert warless says the
pharmaceutical giant is ready to leap
into action with new vaccines
to protect against other possible
variants within 100 days
we have a surveying system in all over
the country in all countries of the
world in all over the world
and when a new variant emerges
immediately we are testing how the
current vaccine
behaves compared to israel we're getting
near the six month mark now
of people here in the u.s getting the
vaccines
have has pfizer determined that we will
need a booster shot
no we haven't determined and the studies
are currently running
but based on the data borla says pfizer
is anticipating people
will need a booster shot essentially a
third dose
within 8 to 12 months of their second
shot
other advances by fall pfizer hopes to
reformulate its covet vaccine so it will
not require
super cold storage and it anticipates
the vaccine will also be approved for
children as young as five
unless if we will be able to vaccinate a
significant percentage of the population
it's very difficult to achieve what we
call herd immunity when you reach her
immunity you protect the others as well
and kids will play a significant role in
doing that
the united states has answered the call
in england president biden said that
worldwide vaccination efforts would be a
constant project for a long time pfizer
is committed to donating a total of two
billion doses over the next year and a
half
most of them going to lower income
countries here in the united states
about half the population has gotten at
least one dose but
in africa uh less than two percent
can we really contain this virus until
we can get it to these countries more
quickly i would like to think that
first and foremost because it is the
right thing to do
but also setting aside the moral
concerns
i think it is also very important for
controlling global
condemning despite the miracle of
science
the fastest ever development of a
vaccine borland now worries about people
who refuse to take it
with vaccination rates slowing down
borla has this message to those who are
reluctant
i try to explain them that
the decision to vaccinate or not is not
going to affect only your life but
unfortunately will
affect the health of others and likely
will affect
the health of people you like and you
love the most when you try to explain
that
their fear could stand in their way to
protect your loved ones i think this is
the argument that
uh mostly works but i think that
argument only works if it comes from
someone in your community not a ceo
or a medical expert somewhere that's
right you need to hear from other people
but i am struck by the
by as jan called it the miracle of
science i mean how effective this
vaccine has been
against all these variants so far yeah
and the g7 is committed to one billion
doses for developing countries but
they need 11 billion says the who wow
it's a big world
yes it is all right jen crawford thank
you